escalada máxima en puertas a medida que
se acerca el primer aniversario de la
incursión a Ucrania Rusia estaría
listando una ofensiva inminente desde
varios frentes al menos así lo cree en
las autoridades de defensa ucraniana
está reuniendo todo lo posible haciendo
simulacros y entrenando en cuanto a una
ofensiva desde diferentes direcciones
por ahora puedo decir que no estamos
excluyendo ningún escenario en las
próximas dos o tres semanas
la perspectiva llega en momentos en que
Ucrania ha recibido nueva ayuda militar
de occidente pero aliados equief
aseguran que no es suficiente como el ex
Primer Ministro británico Boris Johnson
que aprovechó una reunión del Consejo
Atlántico para clamar por el envío de
armas y sistemas de defensa más
sofisticados sin temor a alentar el
conflicto
les imploro ahora que sigan la lógica de
lo que están haciendo y den a los
ucranianos herramientas para terminar el
trabajo denles los sistemas de
artillería de fuego profundo denles los
denle los aviones porque ellos tienen un
plan saben lo que tienen que hacer
pero no es tan sencillo en Bélgica
docenas de tanques uno no operativos se
encuentran enmándose compañías privadas
de seguridad que ofrecen revenderlos al
estado muy por encima de su valor y
Alemania urge por la reposición de los
inventarios que fueron destinados a
Ucrania
para mí el hecho crucial es que debemos
ordenar nuevos tanques no en un año sino
rápidamente para que la producción pueda
comenzar y podamos planificar cuando
Tendremos que cantidad de nuevos
leopardos De dónde vendrá el dinero
pongámoslo así francamente no me importa
es esencial que podamos tenerlo
rápidamente
La pregunta es hasta cuándo tendrá
occidente capacidad de seguirle el paso
a la ofensiva rusa